leschi légèrement vous parler un petit
peu de l'année prochaine ah ah parce que
j'aimerais parler aux téléspectateurs
bien entendu de l'année prochaine vous
donner des chiffres sur touche pas à mon
pote donc un instant mais je vais vous
parler de l'année prochaine et
j'aimerais savoir vous autour de la
table qu'est ce que vous attendez comme
amélioration et l'augmentation une
augmentation c'est clair on va on va
arriver à vous ce que vous attendez pour
l'année prochaine
et j'aimerais voilà qu'on me disait qu
elles sont voilà les sujets où vous vous
sentez les meilleurs si voilà si vous
soyez là l'année prochaine d'un bon oeil
castel de fans abonnés je ne sais pas
alors non je me sens très à l'aise une
stabilité une stabilité on voulait vous
cherchez voilà c'est ça alors cette
émission s'est passé dans la stabilité
sur la durée d'accord après un jour oui
un jour non ça c'est vous qui décidez
mais voilà d'accord donc vous voulez
quoi voilà contraint et moi le vendredi
lents serment est ce qu'on vous
souhaitez une augmentation au jeu et je
veux qu'on dise aux téléspectateurs
équipés ça vu que j'ai fait l'effort de
kobe de de baisser de 30% mais et
munitions et ses munitions
désolé
[Musique]
c'est pas possible c'est vous qui
attendez munitions et 30% de plus de
1000 des munitions ça m'arrangerait
ne quittez pas qu'est ce qui se passe et
ça vous allez quoi bas à 30% de plus
vous les 30% de plus mais pas non on
retrouvait les trombes d'eau que vous
dérange
je note que je vote pour chacun d'eux
castaldi tu veux quoi vous noté avec moi
bien sûr chez vous casse tête d'une veut
30 % pour de plus parce qu'il était
avocat et témoin à moins d'un pourcent
ci sera d'après la conduite du mobile
12e prime non mais dites la vie d'un
homme avait demandé quelque chose de
possible le malheur de prime de près
l'accord de prêt à jouer je vais faire
le tout a cessé après pour chaque
journée après je verrai des gothiques
donc vous puisse rembourser les
vendredis entre les vendredis au voilà
ou à votre place et vendredi - ma place
oui oui à ma place ne sera pas possible
alors avant vous alors pour la régie
sera pas de bon goût après moi mais vous
ne remplacerez clinique veut couler la
chaîne
si je résume non mais ça suffit la plus
crasse et % donc au niveau de preuve est
caché voilà quotidien quotidien oui
quotidien oui que tu as eu de prime les
vendredis oui et de prime par mois ou
par non non non c'est la phase iib moi
et mon film aussi avec vous ah oui ça
s'est bien passé ses films ses
déductions voulez quoi
50/50 bien sûr 55 ans vous êtes on va me
dire que c'est moi qui vais prendre tous
les risques qui va être tout l'argent
voilà c'est ça qu'on partage bien sûr
c'est normal est ce que ça vous semble
équitable comme ben alors écoutez je
reviens vers vous j'ai revient de chez
darty qui travaillent là bas
et alors j'ai ma machine à laver je la
chante est-ce que vous trouvez quelque r
oui il faut que tous les belges
je voudrais je voudrais je souhaiterais
rester dans les mêmes conditions que cet
accord va dire même pas vu d'une
rémunération puisque vous avez été à mon
écoute donc je serai bien malhonnête je
chéris et simplement si je pouvais avoir
en plus un petit rendez vous peu importe
la répare rendez vous allez avoir un
rendez vous à la maison et de la
contacter truc à moi pour retrouver les
téléspectateurs juste eux et moi avec
une petite petite équipe pourquoi pas
d'accord et peu importe bangladais
romancière
voilà un petit tour en dromadaire c'est
donc un rendez vous avec un dromadaire
c'est très bien c'est bon pernikoff
alors moi j'aimerais bien que l'émission
soit un petit peu plus race rare c'est
possible la trouve trop dark 1 cette
saison plus de rats sera d'accord sinon
je suis bien à savoir donc tout va bien
si jamais hissé hockey
même salaire tout paris tout pareil
c'est ok je peux déjà engorgé déjà vous
dire que c'est fait pour delphine
bonsoir ça est ce que vous voulez alors
moi j'achète une maison actuellement
donc effectivement 30 % ou 40 de plus ça
ne gênait pas on va mettre 35
mais je note tout à toi j'ai pas dit non
j'ai pas dit non non répond mais plus
sérieusement moi j'aime beaucoup cette
année l'année 2021 je la sens très très
bien et pour moi et pour les gens c'est
une très belle année donc que ça
continue comme ça et nous ferons bien
sûr le bilan en 2022 merci alors + 35 %
c'est tout pour l'instant oui cette fois
c'est tombé sur des gens gilbert baisse
est ce que je vais vous virer la déposer
parce que chaque année il est viré et je
le jette pas la porte il revient par la
fenêtre et c'est pourquoi donc vous tous
pareils ah non alors quoi a déjà on va
discuter tout l'été comme d'habitude
alors ça comme d'habitude c'est vous qui
déciderez
ce qui n'est pas fou il a pas tort le
même nombre d'émissions par semaine que
cette année est-ce que je vais toujours
vous envoyer des sms à tous oui c'est
parce que je vous explique ce qui se
passe c'est qu'ils négocient avec les
personnes qui l'avaient qui doivent
négocier c'est à dire le directeur
général d'aj 2 on le dirait le directeur
général adjoint fabrice conca et le
directeur général le grand chef lionel
stan et à chaque fois ils m'envoient des
sms ça m'a dit ça et à chaque fois barré
bon écoute je ne suis au courant de rien
la mauvaise c'est vrai mais je reprends
le dossier oui à partir de ce soir c'est
moi qui reprend effectivement monsieur
qu'on cas où monsieur stan nous appelle
c'est on a vu avec syrie mais voilà est
parfaitement d'accord avec ces propos
donc voilà ce qu'on me propose
et quand on voit ce qu'est ce que je
mangeais pas ses nuits des textos mais
c'est bon tu avais tu deviens fou moi la
paix
[Rires]
ce qui sont mes goûts de ses sens je
suis au courant de rien mais vous croyez
qu'on me croit baa croyez moi je vous
dis à barclays jambon la radio j'ai
merdé est ce que vous voulez alors le
même monde des missions contractuelles
si possible donc c'était quoi
16h et trois émissions par semaine dans
la salle non je penserai pas à ce niveau
de la tva je pose au niveau de la tv al
je ne passe pas le moule 10 3 l'émission
par semaine d'accord une petite
augmentation salariale de 15 %
je suis 15% et j'aimerais bien
participer si possible à quelques
balances ton post il veut le coup les
démissions j'aime bien ce que vous
voulez vous avez vous dit oui je veux
dire c'est que les autres on n'aura
jamais le combat au près mais c'est tout
à votre honneur que le patronat écoute
les petits pas et que voilà on voulait
non qu'il écoute non oui oui qui donne
la parole
non non c'est pas vous n'êtes pas du
tout petit bout alors moi je suis père
tu me rendes parce que je ne demande
jamais rien alors je veux pas
d'augmentation très bien minutes parce
que là pour le coup ça serait pas
possible
mais ben non mais regarde même match que
j'aurais pris des occasions pour chaque
jeu de l'agilité chômage aurait bifurqué
bonne idée et d'autres non a suggéré la
a fait alors barça
voudrais juste vous convaincre que je
suis pas complètement con et que je sais
m'exprimer en faisant cours
ça veut dire que donc alors puisque dix
ans ont dévalé une fois sur 10 vous
pouvez me passait la parole se défasse
que vous surprendre angles comme je peux
déjà vous répondra vous tout de suite
c'est non ok - isabelle c'est pas grand
chose donc on va voir
attendez je vais pas fini je croyais que
c'était fini et temps en temps j'aime
bien raconter une histoire ne qu'une
l'histoire de france ou du sexe des
animaux voilà je le donne
histoire de cul de l'histoire de france
oui ou sur les animaux l'essor de serre
des animaux c'est noté piloter mais bon
il va falloir qu'elle fasse ses preuves
bernard montiel alors moi j'ai aimé la
tournure qu'a pris l'émission cette
année c'est à dire qu'il ya peu de
chocolat à la con non non il une
question qu'ovide abendanon alors je ne
signerai pas donc c'est dommage pour
blanc pays bas coût qui va vous allez
avoir du mal à payer votre 120 m² shon
animaux
c'est fini la nîmoise dès que vous
passez quelques mois c'est fini je crois
que c'est fini on au gabon conjurer le
sort jamais de mai nous attend mais
autrement le reste ça va tout va bien
bonjour pourquoi je demande de rien
d'une aux madériens l'ennemi truc ne
demande rien donc je mets deux demandes
de rien donc n'aura rien je le donne
tous ces pauvres voilà j'aurais pu
gagner
alors moi je veux rien de plus rien de
moins je veux toujours mes deux
émissions par semaine sans faute 4 oui
mais voilà un contrat de deux émissions
par semaine ça va dans huit émissions
par mois quoi j'aimerais quand même
demandé une heure de tête à tête avec
vous tous les mois une heure de coaching
un peu haut de gamme à peu exceptionnel
une heure de tennis sekiguchi bavoux
huawei à ce moment alors nous permettant
à payer sur les émissions si parce que
vous m'offrez ça en guise d'augmentation
à de mon trac reuters pendant une heure
de tchimou par mois bon d'accord
1h jeu mature et moi j'ai pas dit oui
j'ai pas dit plus c'est sympa si je
progresse c'est bien pour vous les
gâteaux voilà avec jeu de shoot bien
j'aime bien j'aime bien à la roue moi
j'aimerais un contrat d'exclusivité sur
trois ans votre styliste officiel
[Applaudissements]
là
exclu sur trois ans ouais mon rêve est
ce donc que cette année ça a manqué
d'animations capillaire chez vous c'est
vrai ça a beaucoup jasé d'alcool et au
tgs est d'accord je vous dire une
certaine il s'agit de couleurs cet été
donc je sais pas je vais faire mais les
mecs mois tiendront bien je suis là dans
une routine car quelle horreur c'est à
la mode là c'est le roux nous luttons
contre adelscott le foot hockey plutôt
cupra que de l'épiderme et c'est tout
c'est tout c'est un homme sinon tout va
bien je serai content non vraiment ouais
c'est un avion alors on reprend
il est 19 heures pleines dans un instant
je répondrais est vraiment pas à chacun
d'entre vous sur toutes vos demandes
j'ai tout donné tout noté ok je voudrais
ce qui est possible ce qui n'est pas
possible
d'accord et je vous dirai ce que je peux
faire les chroniqueurs ont fait des
demandes tu as fait des doléances
voilà des points c'est alors qu'elles
sont pas là on l'a on les prendra quand
tu reviens dans la soirée je vais
m'arrêter sur chacun des cas et je veux
vous redire ce qu'ils m'ont demandé je
vous dire si c'est possible
or note possible avant nous annoncer ce
qui est possible ou pas possible je vous
demande d'accueillir le directeur
général d'aj d'eau qui va juste vous
annoncer une bonne nouvelle et qui
repartira
il dira une phrase et il repartira entre
au caire c'est une bonne nouvelle
c'est le directeur général d'ald
production du vaccin
[Applaudissements]
mais faute est porteuse de bonnes
nouvelles
d'excellentes nouvelles pour ceux qui
sont là et les autres aussi des aa
il y aura cette année 0 % de diminution
[Applaudissements]
ce qui est bien c'est vous cet
historique historique à mascara d'art et
biomasse cabalor justement match haché
par les dons par le mascara ou mal et
donc demandé benjamin castaldi à 19h24
je vous le dis benjamin castaldi m'a dit
+ 30 % de plus non666 une 1 lors autour
des 30% au moins deux j'ai concédé à
charbon mieux côté vous dire c'est qu'on
a voulu c'est qu'on n'a pas voulu ouvrir
quand vous reculez si pour vous garer
maintenant que vous êtes carré non mais
ça vous avez passé créneau c'est comme
la chanson si tu avances autonome dieu
vous dire pour les alors même année donc
plus 30 % de plus savez vous dire
débattent non c'est non c'est donc voilà
ça non pour l'argent ce qu'espère
d'amour est dans la cour alors pour la
tromperie temps et je vous dis la chose
tant que l'épidémie n'est pas jugulée à
l'abandon les [ __ ] mais nous restons
dans la configuration commis 19 13 donc
pas de chocolat pas de chocolat exacto
si c'est tout
par contre pourrait prendre une pastèque
dans la salle arena bras c'est très con
vide je trouve pourtant c'est non je
suis désolé deux prime
ah c'est pas non à aa oui c'est ma prime
pour l'instant un prime après monsieur
renaud m bon quoi après sur gênés après
monsieur
[Applaudissements]
les vendre aux dépenses passe et tu te
dis quand même avant c'était pas un
prime non mais après si les 27 premiers
pas du tout mes boots est là tous les
jours on me dit pas assez de présence de
philippe de wade l'hebdomadaire
cwi les vendredis pour me remplacer
c'est oui ah je vois maintenant juste
une chose ça n'a pas arrêté de me
gonfler je reçois encore un c'est mon
téléphone quand vous à répondre dans la
gueule donc on est d'accord d'accord et
pour le film oui c'est oui à 90 10
on va regarder c'est à dire pas mal tous
à la lettre les 6 et montpezat héros de
nevers noir et après cette belle
proposition magnifique mais naim oui
mêmes conditions vous demandez à
rendez-vous médaille mais oui l'année
prochaine il y aura le 6/7 qui va
revenir je vous dis tout l'argent ce
moment là alors je vous dis aussi ce qui
va se passer l'année prochaine
6 à 7 et le 6 à 7
benjamin tu feras les vendredis je me
remplacera bon à prime tu prêt également
de 6 à 7
mais on va tourner ce que sera le 6 et 7
avec cast away ou avec beynat ou avec
bernard bernard montiel voulait dire
aussi des côtés peu de temps donc on est
là et on fera tourner aussi peut-être
l'un d'entre vous qui aura sa chance
soit par fois par mois papa delphine
pourquoi pas delphine c'est ça pourquoi
pas guillaume non mais c'est vrai il va
c'est sympa c'est bien la coiffure aline
c'est un autre style ça vous fait
plaisir ou pas ah bah moi ça fait
plaisir mais je veux pas que ça fasse de
la peine à benjamin il y aura d'autres
choses là non ça va je suis très bien
moi je n'y étais pas et benjamin il va
me remplacer en plus tous les vendredis
dakar serait pas là donc je savais que
le vendredi souvent je démarre et
souvent je termine pas mais là vous nous
avez fait tout ça dès vendredi là je me
suis éclaté j'adore le vendredi en fait
c'est un jour de semaine
bah oui pour moi vous il ya quelques
années la semaine s'est terminée autour
du cas ben arfa qui ne l'a pas dit
pendant toutes ces années hommage de
mercatique basses alpes on comptera sur
le coin de la gueule
personne ne dit rien friday j'ai même à
prendre mais bon vaut lire frei dac
maman donc voilà donc vous n'avez me
remplacer est ce que ça vous plaît ben
moi je vous annonçais un truc de fous
plus là dans un instant balleux déjà il
ya beaucoup d'annoncés tout conducteur
de l'émission dans les projets du genre
l'afutt général à [ __ ] il échangera la
foudre une année exceptionnelle avec des
shows montré des records c'est
incroyable je dirais tous les citoyens
sachent albaz qu'il arrivait dans un
instant et croyez plus pour l'instant
ils restent en chinois est ce que sait
faire de mieux
[Applaudissements]
tu vas rentrer ça vous va ben moi j'ai
pensé si benjamin ça lui posait bien
voilà donc l série glee menaïl jobard
castaldi je bats on passa pernikoff plus
d'aura sera c'est non le même salaire
la même année si oui très fort mais
aussi régler jobard pernikoff super
facile elle fidh j'ai beau calculer un
calcul je ne passe pas mais delphine
toujours aidé bonne nouvelle pour tout
le monde et même ceux qui ne sont pas là
parce qu'il ya tiffany mayer qui élit il
ya que steevy je veux absolument et je
veux absolument qu'ils sont avec moi des
bogeys niaré mon chéri d'amour n'ont
donc tout seul vous inquiétez pas tout
le monde aujourd'hui tout le monde gagne
parmi celles d'otor usine tout le monde
gagne surtout moi
[Applaudissements]
c'est dégueulasse et qu'ici qu'on peut
faire ça c'est pas bizarre bizarre
oui je le dot be there
les 35% plus malheureusement je ne peux
pas par déontologie par rapport aux
autres protagonistes de l'émission
s'était pas de vous voulez pas quoi mais
c'est que voilà pas du tout c'est quoi
ça ou alors une autre écoute et s'il
vous plaît mesdames si vous avez vu
qu'il ya de gros prime qui vont arriver
sur s'est vite les prime sur la pâte à
modeler qui vont cartonner en êtes vous
êtes pour de pâte à modeler je ne
nommerai pas seul à la livrée avec
delphine je dirais même pour l'instant
que c'est delphine qui l'animent seule
vraie meute allait bien mais pour
l'instant est ce que ça vous fait
plaisir ça me fait ça me fait vraiment
très plaisir
non mais vraiment et vous tournerez à
l'animation du 6 à 7 avec géraldine avec
kelly avec vous avec isabelle et
ambiance à ma tournée non merci pas
tarder à me faire chier l'année
bacardi à me faire chier je le note le
besoin de tardi hamon maire dit voilà et
puis quelque chose c'est des gens
profitent quelque chose que j'aime
beaucoup et peut-être vous le savez sur
ces 8 c'est un jour il ya un talk show
où on parle à des gens de leur vie de ce
qu'ils ont failli tout moi ça me plaît
beaucoup à léon la blessure sur ses
stars y aura il y aura des choses comme
ça mais pas dans l'immédiat pas dans
l'immédiat d'autres choses qui vont
arriver peut-être que ce sera au tour de
guillaume guéraud genton une autre
émission jeux wii
gilles verdez c'est toulon c'est tout
non c'est un grand nom mais tout va bien
non alors pour l'augmentation de 15%
sénat pour les btp
cwi
[Applaudissements]
je me sentais d'arlette épique
[Rires]
qu'est ce qui se passe quoi que ça vole
bas et je sens larnack aller où on
n'avait pas abordé le troisième point je
n'ai pas vu à siffloter ckoi 15% non les
in 15% depuis les tp le nombre
d'émissions par semaine ça je pourrais
je ne peux pas le dire la dent 15% c'est
sûr que c'est non comment ça oui ou non
sinon y'a btp mais comme vous allez
faire des btp vous offrir quelques sur
l'année ou à ribou retrouve donc assez
normal at risk et btb l'année prochaine
la turquie avait tout de la wii u est
fermé mais vous aussi n'a pas du tout
mais pas me sucer bon sens votre sens
non c'est une arnaque mais les calculs
et l'a calculé qu apportent souvent des
culées combien vous apporterez un btb
vous faites des bébés toute l'année si
on arrive à juguler les 4% qui avait là
que trois dirigeants et attirer d'autres
ont choisi la 55e à quel âge est là
donc oui je vous laisse avec mon cas
était et pino quoi donc c'est bon
comment ça c'est bon c'est non c'est non
pour moi mais ce que c'est beau non
c'est pas du tout les ayants ils ont là
vous avez vous êtes un chiffre d'aff je
peux tout annuler bon alors c'est long
pour l'instant donc on ne trouve pas de
deal pour la blague il
non il est fou on est des fous isabelle
tout est bon bachiri et je dis oui à
votre petite rubrique l'histoire une
histoire 21e oléronnais l'histoire d'air
france ou des animaux ça sera fait on
sert sinon ça
l'accusé indiqué qu il allait mais on a
des chiffres qui tombent tout les jours
frecon l'entreprise casta beinheim et
moi n'est pas d'accord alors moi alors
que j'ai dû dire ça va être aussi simple
que ça pour la son message que tu n'as
sans donner comme chaque année nos vous
avez 10 à 15 secondes que j'avais un
internat
alors on doit dépasser pour l'instant
benhaim et casta vont faire le 6 et 7
mai les données aussi un jeu ne peut
plus libéré il va faire déjà ça ou les
toutes les chaînes qu'il a toutes les
chaînes et les radios qu'il a coulé dans
les sachets le masque sacha prépare-toi
plus tôt pour lundi forêt
je suis en négociation repas ce lundi à
du lourd l'a dit c'est toujours le plus
fort c'est donc pas samedi par des gens
se battent maintenant tu te fais le jour
mais tu prends ta douche tout ce qui
touche au jeu passera juste une tête
pour que les gens me voient ils voient
que ce papa à la personne le pou ne me
regarde ce coup bernard montiel donc
pour l'instant il a rien rien géant
d'imagés deux émissions par mois pas
d'augmentation semaine oui c'est bon
alors c'est bon une heure de coaching de
tennis par mois ces valeurs a cédé du
terrain mais c'est le tennis
ouais ça je croyais que c'était un
coaching de vie comme ça comptera sur
trois ans en tant que visage nous est à
ranger derrière je ne peux pas vous avez
une nouvelle idée de couleur peau alors
je vous dis hein quand je vois votre
couleur bas mais dimanche au coin du feu
dimanche au coin du feu un blond cendré
un peu après dimanche au coin du feu n'a
dû son poing dans la gueule tu le
connais se situe la connaissance couleur
ça donc dimanche au coin du feu dimanche
au coin du feu
c'est quoi c'est un blond cendré c'est
un peu gris comme ça tu m'interpelle des
tirs sans l'euro forcément pourquoi nous
ferons des décotes de
c'est pas les mettre dans ses statuts
les mettre en garde et donc qu'est ce
que vous voulez c'est tout pas
d'augmentation non ça et vous inquiétez
pas il ya des choses qui arrivent c'est
vrai ah oui merci sûr qu'il y ait aussi
il va faire des choses parce que je le
considère comme quelqu'un d'extrêmement
talentueux dans l'animation
non non non en tant que centre robert
lui trouver sa place voilà donc vous il
y aura des choses merci